Poor women who cook have healthier diets than wealthy women who don't.
Rates of home cooking decline,
rates of obesity go up. And then you have the industry
with marketing messages that are flattering our sense of business
and pleasantly telling us,
you don't have time to cook,
you're too important, you're a loser if you have time to cook.
So I do tell the story of how we came to this,
how a culture of home cooking was dismantled,
deliberately dismantled, by the food industry,
which took out billboards in the early 70s across America
with a giant bucket of fried chicken,
you know,
the red thing with the 14 pieces of chicken popping out of the top,
and just a two word slogan,
women's liberation is very,
very clever, because they redefined not cooking,
which was kind of in distribute before this,
as the progressive thing to do.
And men grabbed at this and women grabbed at this
because it essentially solved a problem
once again. Create an anxiety,
solve a problem. And women who weren't working also there